this is going to be the one i can feel
it man i can't feel it
oh my god
we got it guys
you know is this no this is not
so we have those two hot selling
collections right here the disney
animals and yo-yo young's gemstone
prince and let's just get started with
the disney animal shall we
[Music]
and with the disney animals box set we
have actually done our research and the
hidden one here is actually predita from
101 dalmatian so let's hope we actually
get that
nice let's go
so this is the feeling of opening
a box set instead of
a single
[Music]
a single blind box
so
the rituals with unboxing these toys of
course you're not supposed to press hold
or squeeze them before you buy
so we would recommend you not to do that
in the store but if you have actually
purchased an entire box set you are free
to do whatever you want with them and
why not have fun with it as well so the
blind boxes also have the list of all
the figurines displayed here and you can
check out this one over here it is the
hidden one that we actually want to look
for even though we have no clue what it
looks like but
we're just gonna try and hopefully get
our way and get our luck with
101 dalmatian figurine then some of
these figurines actually differ in
weight and sizes and even design as you
can tell from bumby or even dumbo they
are slightly bigger than the rest of the
figurines so hopefully we'll be able to
try and find out which one of these
blind boxes belong to either one of them
is it me
they all look the same
they all feel the same it just feels
slightly heavier
two of them has got to be bambi or
or dumbo so i'm going to open this one
up straight away
let's see if my my guess is right
and if you can get a
oh so they still come in wrapped
red packaging so you still don't know
what the figurines are but i believe
they do have a card inside which tells
you
which figurine this is and
oh no they don't oh they do
this is timon timon spider i always have
to save your
time has a slightly bigger head so
it's not too bad
i think it's
kite is so cute
check out the details on this figurine
especially the water droplet and the
cute little ladybug on top of the set
the painting and the sculpting is
amazing for figuring that's about 10 to
20 dollars so let's continue unboxing
and of course my bets on these two that
we will get either dumbo or bambi but i
might be wrong might be right let's get
down to it i'm not gonna even look at
the card
i'm gonna go straight into opening this
package for that gacha feeling oh man
i'm wrong again
i'm wrong again what do we have here we
have mary
i'll show you if i'm a lady or not
which i am not too familiar with
unfortunately the reason why it's heavy
is because of the cake i believe check
out this accessory that came with mary
if you didn't notice that this is
actually made of felt instead of the
usual plastic
that's the kind of quality
pokemon is trying to put in their toys
[Music]
and it's really incredible for something
something so small they are able to put
all these details and and work into it
this is awesome this is awesome
come on man come on
i got a good feeling about this oh my
god
looks like i'm not too good with opening
um guessing boxes uh what do we have
here we have
this is this is trumper thumper tamper
with the flower there is a flower in it
oh yeah
so tumble comes with a flower and we can
kind of uh
let him hold this
and then this is supposed to go
inside his or her hand i have no clue so
check out thumper's feet and even the
petals uh it's all extremely detailed
painted really well the quality is
top-notch and and even for figuring so
small it's amazing how they can come up
with this quality
well this is this is
this is pumbaa from banking
[Music]
awesome small little
lock
not a lock more like a stump that you
can place him on
oh this is cute slurping some spaghetti
[Music]
some of these accessories are extremely
delicate so you got to be careful with
them you don't want to break them so
just safely
and slowly put the fork into the plate
of spaghetti over here and voila
awesome
and well we already know this is simba
which is
i believe my favorite out of all these
12 because simba come on guys
[Music]
yo yo don't do it
don't do it
yo
look at the amazing paint job they have
done here with zazu even though it's
extremely
extremely small and extremely cute
the paint job is still on point no
smudges everything is
smooth
everything is perfect
i have zero complaints
and then you can simply
put this on simba and
this is my favorite
this is gonna be my favorite
it is maybe
oh no how we have failed
and we have this little butterfly
same like zazu for simba extremely well
painted and detailed you can put in i'll
put the butterfly on top of uh
what i'm gonna do is believe
what's this
let's see if i can feel my way
this feels like a teammate
it is a teammate guys but only because i
i opened up the package
[Music]
timothy is holding a little cute peanut
how i mean how adorable is that
it comes with the feather that you can
put on top of his head there we go
little timothy
i can feel it man this is going to be
the one
i can't feel it
oh my god you got it guys
you know is this no this is not this is
pongo
[Music]
this is not even a 101
such disappointment
that's quality content right there
oh man
i probably had the one-on-one donation
it is the 101 domination but it is not
her
it's unfortunate
that's all right it's all right
i just surprised myself for no reason
and of course dumbo
over here top
over here
last two guys come on we're like out of
all these we do not have lady flower and
of course the secret one so it's two out
of three chances i like to see that as a
high possibility of us getting a secret
producer from 101 it is not pretty it's
hard from 101 but we have lady with last
year and she looks really cute really
elegant in a really nice pose
and no accessories as well last one guys
this has got to be the one
this has got to be the one i believe
if you believe things are going to
happen man actually it does i'll be
honest it doesn't feel like flower it
doesn't feel like flower this is it guys
the moment of truth
[Music]
all right so here we go we have the
entire box set right in front of us so
if you don't want replicas repeats or
buying one boxes by one boxes go for the
entire set and you will get every single
one of these collectible figurines in
the box set
but unfortunately we didn't get
ourselves
one of the secret edition one-on-one
donation per data but it's all right
maybe we can get one more box
i'm not too sure about that but yeah
we're gonna be moving on to the next box
[Music]
you